il a créé l'association criminelle la
plus puissante de Naples avec l'aide de
sa sœur voici l'histoire de la fratrie
la plus célèbre de la Camorra Rosetta et
Raphaël écoute Dolo
[Musique]
nous sommes au début des années 80 dans
le sud de l'Italie les morts
s'accumulent dans les rues de Naples
deux organisations criminelles
s'affrontent pour le contrôle du
territoire la nova familiale et la nova
Camorra organisateurs
malicieux qui est à la tête de la Mova
Camorra organisata il est surnommé le
professeur
[Musique]
à octaviano dans la région de Naples il
commence sa carrière criminel des
l'adolescence sous l'œil de sa grande
sœur Rosetta faut qu'il y a marathon
le mercato miss est la pistolet
à 21 ans Raphaël est couteau l'eau
commet son premier meurtre il est Coop
de 24 ans de prison derrière les
barreaux il se consacrent à la lecture
et à la poésie et gagne le surnom de
professeur
lors quantonios pavonner l'un des grands
chefs de la Camorra entre à la prison de
Boggio real il le défi au combat au
couteau mais celui-ci refuse Raphaël et
coutolleau se fait un nom
il fédère autour de lui plusieurs
criminels et le 24 octobre 1974 jour de
la Saint Raphaël il crée son
organisation la NCO la caméra
[Musique]
la NCO devient rapidement un réseau
criminel organisé derrière les barreaux
et dans les rues de Naples forte d'une
structure pyramidale presque militaire
l'organisation de Don Rafael ambitionne
de rivaliser avec les grandes mafia
comme la Coza nostra sicilienne et la
dangleta calabraise dont elle
s'approprie les codes et les rites et
outils
de
fond et prélève une taxe sur le trafic
de drogue
Raphaël dirige depuis sa cellule par
l'intermédiaire de sa soeur
l'organisation criminelle la plus
puissante de Naples
[Musique]
organisation
contrer l'influence croissante de la NCO
sur le crime organisé les autres clans
napolitain décide de s'allier pour la
première fois de leur histoire ensemble
il crée la nova familiale
peut compter sur plusieurs milliers
d'hommes totalement acquis à sa cause et
ténébreux la photographie
l'organisation et l'organisation la vie
protège quinnie par la prime
son autonomie et s'émanciper des
ingérences de Cosa Nostra la mafia
sicilienne qui soutient ses ennemis de
la nova familia pour cela il décide de
s'allier avec des clans de la drugueta
calabraise
des crimes à Naples a perdu
son caractère romantique elle est
devenue
plus violente elle est devenue une
grande organisation au caractère
technocrate donner Raphaël souhaite
également retrouver les valeurs de la
camarade du 19e siècle et renouée avec
les origines mystiques de la mafia et
l'eau et là on a sorti
le 23 novembre 1980 la terre trembla
erpignan à quelques kilomètres de Naples
un séisme de magnitude 6.9 frappe la
région de Campanie le bilan est lourd
plus de 2700 morts et toute une région à
reconstruire une aubaine pour la mafia
l'année suivante chez rhello le
conseiller régional chargé de la
reconstruction est enlevé par les
Brigades Rouges l'organisation d'extrême
gauche qui terrorise l'Italie des années
de plomb les services secrets et
certains hommes politiques de démocratie
chrétienne le parti au pouvoir
contactent les chefs mafieux pour le
faire libérer
Rafael et coutolo accepte en échange de
traitement de faveur dans l'attribution
des marchés publics
cyrilo sera libéré après 89 jours de
séquestration
économique et les couteaux lots
finissent par manquer d'argent plusieurs
cadres de l'organisation sont morts ou
derrière les barreaux et en 1985 la
novakamura est définitivement morte
lorsque tout la devinta pyramidale
est assassiné par un clan rival mais
monsieur bonsoir Après le parrain la
marraine Rosetta couteau vient d'être
arrêté aujourd'hui après avoir échappé
pendant 13 ans à la police Rosetta
kutolo est condamné à 9 ans de prison
pour association mafieuse elle est
libérée après sept ans et retourna
Ottaviano où elle vit encore aujourd'hui
cette février 2021 Raphaël et les
couteaux meurent à l'hôpital militaire
de Parme à l'âge de 79 ans après avoir
été incarcéré pendant 57 ans
[Musique]